und wir schauen auf den russischen krieg
und das ist wirklich eine ganz besonders
perfide art der psychologischen
kriegsführung
das russische militär soll ukrainische
bürger im kriegsgebiet festnehmen und
sie dann gegen ihren willen nach
russland ins deputation lager bringen
das ist der vorwurf aus amerika erhält
in der sitzung des un-sicherheitsrats in
new york das unmenschliche daran unter
den deputierten sind offenbar auch
kinder und weiter es soll wird
tatsächlich glaubwürdige berichte geben
das ukrainische kinder von ihren eltern
getrennt und nach russland deportiert
werden damit sie dort schnell
eingebürgert und zur adoption
freigegeben werden können das sagt die
chefin des un menschenrechts berufs
schätzungen zufolge seien so schon
zwischen 900.000 1,6 millionen menschen
aus ihren heimatorten deportiert worden
das sagte us-botschafterin länder tomsk
rentiert
[Musik]